I want to have all my me and my husband
I'm done with the ideal family it
doesn't work anymore people don't think
like that until you go ahead people
don't think like that no that's why
you're fighting so much no no that's
what you don't think like that everybody
else does anyway so when she was talking
about when you were saying oh that was
your father working she was like yeah
your father's he was always away and he
was always there how many homes did your
father where did he live he traveled all
the time for what but when he came home
where was home so she can't say that
because we live in separate houses that
is the same as your dad being absent
being at work because you came home yeah
she has a man and they have separate the
man could never call where his child is
home because the child's gonna have two
separate arms so it's not the same as
your father being away because your
father knew where home was he always
came home and he knows it's in his home
you can have we can be my neighbor if
you want like just don't live in my
house I don't want that I think I'm just
tired
well then didn't you guys say that women
should be more logic there we go
around
if it was logical she would have thought
about it she would have thought about
the pros and cons of the child she would
have listened to the stats and then she
would have thought about the child you
know about the child so you're not
thinking logically because a man if a
man's thinking logically he wouldn't be
he wouldn't be thinking well let me do
this and let me do that logically we're
thinking this is what's going to happen
to my child well it's like 80 of this is
happening to the child and this is what
I'll be thinking about the child it is
not
because they think about the
practicality or being present women tend
to be the first to want divorce
wait wait wait how is it that us living
in several houses means he's not present
because it's a separate house
okay okay let's let's talk to someone
who's done it let's talk to someone
wait wait wait
Christ
um Sarah you you went from being in a
relationship yeah to now you co-parent
yes is it the same no tell me about the
differences it's not the same even
though right now you it's successful
peaceful roughly co-parenting right so
tell me tell me about the differences
the the child is a child when they wake
up in the morning and they see both
parents in the house and then they come
home
from school and they see both parents in
the house they and if they get used to
that um Dynamic right when that is
removed from them there is a schism
that they have to go through within
their own mind and it happened with my
child oh I won't lie happen with him he
had to get used to going to Daddy's
house and Mommy's house right he's used
to Mommy and Daddy being together right
so you've now got to explain to that
child oh you know what
um daddy's not there because so and so
and so and so and we still you know
we're still cool with your mom and dad
but the thing is what happens is they
get children are not stupid people think
children are stupid you guys have all
been children we've all been children we
know we've picked up on certain things
when it comes to our parents and we'd be
like um okay children pick up on things
okay you are in in my personal point of
view you are very selfish okay you're
thinking about yourself you're not
thinking about children you're not
thinking about the idol situation for
children the ideal situation for any
child and even as a child yourself you
know that it would be being in a
household with both mom and dad even
even a pearl situation Dad wasn't there
all the time the child knows in the back
of their mind this is still Daddy's
house this is still where Dad lives dad
doesn't live outside the house he works
outside the house but he still lives
here with Mom Dad and the rest of us
Maya highlights of key difference your
situation came through togetherness and
separation if you're not together from
the beginning the conversation is
different secondly secondly secondly
when we are then talking about it's not
an adult situation yeah no for a child
I'm saying not for you
I want to explain to you why because
Mommy and Daddy love each other Mommy
and Daddy they may live in separate
houses if I see daddy mommy all the time
and every time they're together they
smile because they're giving themselves
the space because they respect each
other and their main goal together their
relationship is based on making sure
that I am okay as a child which means
daddy takes care of me mommy please
let me say something you've created a
whole scenario that doesn't even
existence
you've created a fictional scenario that
in your head right exists and makes
sense in your head no no but it's not
dreams because children children are not
subject to your dreams children are
subject to the environment and the
situation that they are in them
kids aren't stupid crazy and one day
kids notice if their mother is selfish
and the question is if they know one day
that you chose to put them at every
statistical disadvantage and I've talked
to to kids where their parents are
separate I actually my my mom um her
parents were separated they were like
lived in separate houses and it's not
fun and and some some of the some of the
kids were really mad at the parents for
doing that yeah
but wait wait kids aren't stupid one day
they grow up and they notice that their
mother is selfish and the question is do
they forgive you for being selfish
I'm telling you know they don't say
sickness you know what I've ever
Impressions things and people are going
to say I'm triggered you know what
because
I am triggered one thing that you forgot
to to mention Sarah is that
not only does the child have to get used
to the two parents living in different
houses that child's no longer special at
school
that child now has to explain to his
friends while it has to go there at a
weekend and while it has to go there and
I've met selfish women like you and when
they're talking about suicide because
you might think it's funny but I've met
a woman like you and her son threw
himself under a train I love that kid
dearly because of selfish people because
that's exactly what you wanted to do go
and find a friend that she got on with
have a child for a friend that weren't
going to be together and so they can it
[ __ ] up the children's heads
don't no it was like you oh we're really
good friends we're gonna have a child
together and we're gonna call parent it
don't work it messes up what the
children said so you're gonna swear for
them think that you know it all right
because you're gonna be the exception
they don't work for them out there and
you see her don't [ __ ] her boy
because it is like kind of half time I
mean you do need to read the super chats
bro
I haven't said much
I feel like you're you probably maybe
you've experienced or seen situations
that haven't been successful because
it's Auntie Jenny you've been really
married for 32 years in a relationship
my marriage oh okay in a relationship
for 32 years and even that that is
like that's a serious commitment and
maybe you don't you don't see like the
positives out that situation because
there are parents that do love each
other fall in love and then
unfortunately they stay in the situation
because of their children that's also an
unhealthy situation even if they are
living in the same house so I think
maybe that's where your angle but that's
not always the way that it's gonna go
and I think it's about the person that
you choose yeah believe in the person I
mean it's true but then if we're going
to face everything as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible